But what if we wanted to add these 2 fractions together? What do you think we
could do? Well, adding these 2 rational expressions together is very similar to
adding 2 fractions together. If the denominators are different, we need to
change each fraction. By finding the lowest common denominator first. We know
the lowest common denominator would be 90, the product of these factors. We
multiply 1 10th by nine over nine, which is the missing factor from ten. 1 10th
by 9 9ths is 9 90ths. For 1 18th we multiply by five over five. This is the
missing factor for 18. So 1 18th time 5 5ths is 5 90ths. Now we add these 2
fractions just as we learned before. 9 plus 5 equals 14 and we have 14 90ths.
These numbers are both even and so we can reduce them by 2. So these are a
couple of fractions.